the State Department has told a key
figure in president Trump's Ukraine
lobbying effort not to answer questions
from Congress today as scheduled
Gordon Sandlin the US ambassador to the
European Union had agreed to speak with
House impeachment investigators Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill so Nancy he
said he would speak and now he's not
showing up what does this mean for
future witnesses well what it means
Democrats fear is that other state
Department officials who have been
scheduled to be deposed won't show up
either this cancellation took everyone
by surprise
Soglin himself had flown in from
Brussels for this deposition and
according to his lawyer quote early this
morning the u.s. Department of State
directed ambassador Sandlin not to
appear today for his scheduled
transcribed interview the lawyer says
ambassador Sunland is very disappointed
that he won't be able to testify and
that he hopes this is cleared up soon so
that he can but Democrats are already
citing this as another instance of
obstruction of justice by this
administration they want to talk to
Sandlin because he was pushing the
president's priorities in Ukraine harder
than just about anyone namely priorities
that included investigations into the
2016 election and into the energy
company that hunter Biden worked for in
one text message Sandlin insisted that
there was no quid pro quo that's what
Democrats had wanted to ask him about
today well Nancy that certainly is a
plot twist who else does the committee
want to hear from well most notably they
want to hear from the one and now
possibly two whistleblowers who have
come forward they've been engaged in
conversations with the whistleblowers
lawyer trying to get security clearances
lined up so that they can conduct this
closed-door interview however the
President and other Republicans have
said so frequently that they want to be
able to confront this whistleblower
perhaps have him testify publicly the
president says he wants to meet his
accuser that Democrats say they're now
considering extraordinary measures to
conceal this whistleblowers identity
when he does go before
Congress they say they're thinking about
obscuring his face or his voice or
altering them perhaps having him testify
remotely because they're so concerned
that his not anonymity will be blown
Nancy thank you very much